On 15 December 2014, a lone wolf terrorist inspired by Islamic State walked into the Link Cafe in Sydney's Martin Place, armed with a pump-action shotgun, and the threat of a backpack bomb. Over 16 hours, he held 18 hostages captive in a siege that was live-streamed around the world. Tiger Tiger Tiger tells the untold story of the courageous actions of the New South Wales Tactical Operations Unit. This book will challenge what you thought you knew about the Lint siege, with details that show how willing the Tactical Operations Unit operators were to sacrifice their lives. But Tiger Tiger Tiger is more than an edge of your seat inside his perspective on Australia's first terrorist hostage rescue mission.
2014年12月15日，一名受伊斯兰国启发的“独狼”恐怖分子，手持泵动式霰弹枪，并扬言携带背包炸弹，闯入了悉尼马丁广场的林特咖啡馆。在长达16小时的围困中，他劫持了18名人质，整个过程通过网络向全球直播。《老虎，老虎，老虎》讲述了新南威尔士州战术行动小组英勇行动的幕后故事。这本书将挑战你对林特咖啡馆围困事件的既有认知，书中细节展示了战术行动小组的成员们是多么愿意为了拯救人质而牺牲自己的生命。但《老虎，老虎，老虎》不仅仅是一部让你身临其境、深入了解澳大利亚首次恐怖人质营救任务的作品。
Written by the officer who shot and killed the terrorist, this extraordinary frontline account provides an insight into the psychological damage done in the line of duty. It offers a message of resilience and hope for everyone. Tiger, tiger, tiger had me gripped from start to end. I finished it in two days because I simply couldn't put it down. Visit tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com to grab your copy. That's tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com Our episodes deal with serious and often distressing incidents. If you feel at any time you need support, please contact your local crisis centre. For suggested phone numbers for confidential support,
这本书由那位击毙恐怖分子的警官撰写，这份非凡的前线记录提供了对履行职责过程中所造成的心理创伤的深刻见解。它为每个人提供了关于韧性和希望的信息。《老虎，老虎，老虎》从头到尾都深深吸引着我。我只用了两天就读完了，因为我根本停不下来。访问 tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com 获取你的副本。网址是 tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com。我们的节目涉及严肃且往往令人痛苦的事件。如果你在任何时候感到需要支持，请联系你当地的危机中心。如需获取保密支持的建议电话号码，
please see the show notes for this episode on your app or on our website. This episode was originally released on Casefile's Patreon, Apple Premium and Spotify Premium feeds as an early bonus for our paid subscribers. These episodes are designed to be slightly shorter, allowing us to cover a broader range of cases. To receive these episodes early and add free, you can support CaseFile on your preferred platform. Shortly before 3pm on Saturday, January 14, 2012, the doorbell rang at the Howe family home.
请查看你手机应用或我们网站上本集的节目说明。本集最初作为付费订阅者的早期福利，发布在Casefile的Patreon、Apple Premium和Spotify Premium频道上。这些剧集旨在稍微缩短时长，使我们能够涵盖更广泛的案件。要提前收听这些剧集并享受无广告体验，你可以在你偏好的平台上支持CaseFile。2012年1月14日，星期六，下午3点前不久，豪（Howe）家的门铃响了。
49-year-old Chun Num answered it. Standing on his doorstep was a teenage boy whom Chun Num didn't recognize. It seemed reasonable to assume he had come to see one of Chun Nams two children. When asked who he was looking for, the boy explained that he wanted to speak to Vinci. Vinci was Chun Nams 15-year-old daughter. Chun Nams called for Vinci, who appeared at the top of the staircase. She said she would speak with the boy. Chun Nam retreated to the kitchen to prepare dinner, leaving Vinci and her male gased alone.
49岁的春南（Chun Num）去开了门。站在门口的是一个春南不认识的十几岁男孩。他理所当然地认为这孩子是来找春南的两个孩子中的一个。当被问及在找谁时，男孩解释说他想找文西（Vinci）。文西是春南15岁的女儿。春南叫了文西，她出现在楼梯顶端。她说她会和那个男孩谈谈。春南退回厨房准备晚餐，留下文西和她的男性访客单独相处。
Moments later, Chun Nam heard Vinci cry out in pain and he rushed back into the foyer. He was immediately struck in the face with a knife, leaving a bleeding gash across his right cheek. Chun Nam raised his hands for protection, while simultaneously trying to fly it off his assailant. The commotion alerted Chun Nam's 12-year-old son, who rushed in to find his father grappling with a teenage boy holding a knife. The teen managed to stab Chunnam several more times in the face, head and arms before
片刻之后，春南听到文西痛苦的尖叫声，他冲回门厅。他的脸部立刻被刀划伤，右脸颊留下一道流血的伤口。春南举起双手保护自己，同时试图击退袭击者。骚动惊动了春南12岁的儿子，他冲进来发现父亲正与一个持刀的十几岁男孩扭打在一起。那个少年设法又在春南的脸部、头部和手臂上刺了几刀，然后
fleeing out the front door. Lying nearby at the base of the stairs was Vinci. Her face was covered in blood. Vinci Howe lived in the Dutch city of Arnhem. She was a popular secondary school student with an active social life and to many friends. In her spare time, Vinci visited herself with a variety of hobbies, including dancing for a street crew, learning piano, and playing chess. Vinci had adopted the western name Joyce, but her family still referred to her by her
从前门逃走。躺在附近楼梯底部的是文西。她的脸被血覆盖。文西·豪住在荷兰城市阿纳姆。她是一名受欢迎的中学生，有着活跃的社交生活和许多朋友。在业余时间，文西忙于各种爱好，包括为街舞队跳舞、学习钢琴和下棋。文西采用了西方名字乔伊斯（Joyce），但她的家人仍然用她的
Chinese heritage name Vinci. While she drew friends from diverse circles, Vinci mostly gravitated towards other teenagers of Chinese descent like her. Reports of the attack on Vinci and her father spread quickly online. Many of Vinci's friends learned of her ordeal through social media. As Vinci and Chun Nam were rushed to hospital, police worked swiftly to track down their attacker. Vince's brother was able to provide a description.
中文名字文西称呼她。虽然她的朋友来自不同的圈子，但文西主要还是倾向于和其他像她一样的华裔青少年交往。关于文西和她父亲遇袭的消息在网上迅速传开。文西的许多朋友通过社交媒体得知了她的遭遇。当文西和春南被紧急送往医院时，警方迅速展开行动追踪袭击者。文西的哥哥能够提供嫌疑人的外貌特征。
Several of the how family's neighbors had seen the blood soaked teen fleeing the area. Within two hours of the attack, police tracked the boy down to a street north of where the how's lived. He was hiding in some bushes and refused to give himself up. The police fired a single gunshot into the air as a warning, prompting the teen to surrender. The offender was a 14-year-old from Capell and Eiraisal, about two hours west of Varnam. As he was a minor at the time, he has never been fully publicly identified. In reports, he was only referred to as Yinhua K. Yinhua had been kicked out of school
豪家的一些邻居看到了那个浑身是血的少年逃离该地区。袭击发生后两小时内，警方在豪家居住地以北的一条街道上追踪到了这个男孩。他躲在灌木丛中，拒绝投降。警方鸣枪示警，促使该少年投降。罪犯是一名来自卡佩勒（Capelle aan den IJssel）的14岁少年，该地位于阿纳姆以西约两小时车程。由于他当时是未成年人，他的身份从未完全公开。在报道中，他仅被称为“Yinhua K”。Yinhua在
five months earlier and already had a criminal record for two propertyences. Investigators determined that Yinhua and Vinci Hao were not France, but they were superficially acquainted. They shared the same social circles and were known to have attended at least one gathering together months earlier. A photograph taken at this party showed Yinhua pulling a funny face. Two girls stood on either side of him. One was Vinci Howe. Yin Hua eventually confessed to stabbing Vinci and her father. It took a while longer to establish why. Yin Hua finally admitted that the attack wasn't his idea.
五个月前被学校开除，并且已经有两次财产犯罪的前科。调查人员确定，Yinhua和文西·豪并不是朋友，但他们是泛泛之交。他们共享同一个社交圈，并且已知在几个月前至少参加过一次聚会。在那次聚会上拍摄的一张照片显示，Yinhua在做鬼脸。两个女孩站在他两边。其中一个是文西·豪。Yinhua最终承认刺伤了文西和她的父亲。确定动机花了一些时间。Yinhua最终承认，这次袭击并非出自他自己的主意。
He had been recruited to kill Vinci by a 17-year-old reported as Wesley C. Wesley was also Chinese Dutch and lived in Rotterdam. When interviewed, Wesley denied knowing Inwa or having any involvement in the attack. In all, neither Yinhua nor Wessley were particularly helpful to the police. Investigators combed through the two boys' social media, hoping to establish a connection between them.
他是由一名17岁、被称为“Wesley C”的少年招募来杀害文西的。Wesley也是华裔荷兰人，住在鹿特丹。在接受采访时，Wesley否认认识Yinhua或参与了这次袭击。总而言之，Yinhua和Wesley对警方都没有提供特别有用的帮助。调查人员仔细搜查了这两个男孩的社交媒体，希望能建立他们之间的联系。
They eventually came across a conversation between the pair on the telecommunications app, Skype. The day before Vinci and her father were attacked, Wesley and the Inua had exchanged a series of messages. Wesley told the Inua, tomorrow you will do it. Inua responded, okay man, is good. Wesley then provided Yinhua with specific instructions on how to carry out the stabbing before stating, you have the address, you know where to be. She has piano lessons at 2 p.m., so you have to go at 3 p.m. Yinhua responded, okay, if her parents are home, should I take them with me?
他们最终在电信应用Skype上发现了两人之间的对话。在文西和她父亲遇袭的前一天，Wesley和Yinhua交换了一系列信息。Wesley告诉Yinhua：“明天你就动手。”Yinhua回复道：“好的，伙计，没问题。”Wesley随后向Yinhua提供了关于如何实施刺杀的具体指示，并说道：“你有地址，你知道该去哪里。她下午2点有钢琴课，所以你必须在下午3点去。”Yinhua回复道：“好的，如果她父母在家，我应该把他们也一起解决掉吗？”
Wesley's final message, red. Yes, that's okay. Chun Num Hau recovered from his injuries and was released from hospital, but his daughter was in a dire state. Vinci had sustained several deep stubwurns to her face and knack. Five days after the attack, she died. The next day, 600 mourners marched through the city silently alongside Vinci's family in a show of support. The route took them past the house home,
Wesley的最后一条信息写道：“是的，没问题。”春南·豪从伤势中恢复并出院，但他的女儿情况危急。文西的脸部和颈部遭受了多处深刺伤。袭击发生五天后，她去世了。第二天，600名哀悼者在文西家人的陪同下默默穿过城市，以示支持。游行路线经过了豪家，
where a large collection of flowers and soft toys had been placed in honor of Vinci. At the end of the march, a representative of the house family thanked the crowd. Vinci's murder was described by her loved ones as incomprehensible. They asked, how could boys aged 14 and 17 without any relation to Finzi commit such a heinous act on an innocent and defenseless 15-year-old
那里摆放了大量鲜花和毛绒玩具，以纪念文西。游行结束时，豪家的一位代表感谢了人群。文西的谋杀案被她的亲人描述为不可理喻。他们问道，两个14岁和17岁、与文西毫无关系的男孩，怎么能对一个无辜且手无寸铁的15岁
girl? What could be the motive? The family also made it clear that in these circumstances they viewed Dutch punishment for juveniles as inadequate. They called for Yinhua and Wesley to be tried as adults, stating that anyone who could commit such a bloody and premeditated act of violence was no longer a child. The following weekend, Vinci's friends hold a small gathering of their own. They let Chinese lanterns and released them into the night sky. One of the attendees filmed part of the service. The footage captured Vinci's 16-year-old best friend, Polly, saying goodbye to Vinci.
女孩做出如此令人发指的行为？动机可能是什么？家人还明确表示，在这种情况下，他们认为荷兰对未成年人的惩罚是不够的。他们呼吁将Yinhua和Wesley作为成年人审判，称任何能犯下如此血腥且蓄意暴力行为的人都不再是孩子了。接下来的周末，文西的朋友们举行了一个小型的聚会。他们点亮了孔明灯，并将它们放飞到夜空中。其中一名参加者拍摄了仪式的一部分。录像捕捉到了文西16岁的闺蜜波莉（Polly）向文西告别的画面。
But it was the tone of her voice that stood out. Instead of speaking with sadness, Polly sounded noticeably gleeful. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from Case File Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works for a long time now. It will be hosted by Raquel O'Brien, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves, was the first show released on the case for our Presents Platform. After getting to know Raquel
但她说话的语气非常引人注目。波莉听起来并没有悲伤，反而显得异常高兴。Casefile稍后回来。感谢你通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。我很高兴宣布推出《Unfiltered》，这是Case File Presents旗下的最新播客。《Unfiltered》筹备已久。它将由拉奎尔·奥布莱恩（Raquel O'Brien）主持，她非凡的播客《Silent Waves》是Case File Presents平台上发布的第一档节目。在了解拉奎尔之后，
and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people for more walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind. Although I don't host the show, unfiltered has several tie-ins with CaseFile. The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given. It's a long chat, and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly.
并看到她在采访各行各业的人时是多么有天赋，我知道她必须拥有自己的对话式播客，于是《Unfiltered》诞生了。这是一个探索人类经验的播客。没有话题是禁区。这些原始而诚实的对话将为你打开一系列视角，并邀请你做出自己的判断。虽然我不是该节目的主持人，但《Unfiltered》与CaseFile有几个关联。第一集包含了我有史以来第一次深度采访。这是一次长谈，你会了解到一些我从未公开谈论过的事情。
Recurl is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with. The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin White and his former sergeant John Deem joined Recull to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes. Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation.
拉奎尔是我唯一感到可以进行这种对话的人。第二集的主角是Case File第78案“Janabi家族案”中的两位关键证人。前美国士兵贾斯汀·怀特（Justin White）和他的前中士约翰·迪姆（John Deem）加入了拉奎尔，讲述他们在战争中的经历，以及揭露战争罪行是什么感觉。未来的剧集将邀请来自各行各业的多元化嘉宾。有些与Case File的剧集或我们的Case File Presents系列有关，而另一些则完全无关。但所有剧集都讲述了关于正义与转变的真实故事。
The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now, wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for Unfiltered, so you don't miss an episode. Hey everybody, this is Jake Johnson. And Garrett Reynolds. And we're inviting you to listen to our new podcast we're here to help. Yeah, we're an advice podcast where people call in with their problems and we try to help. We try, we can't stress this enough, we are not professionals and we're not even very good at this.
包括我那期采访在内的前两集现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听，后续所有剧集将每周发布。请务必点击《Unfiltered》的关注按钮，这样你就不会错过任何一集。大家好，我是杰克·约翰逊（Jake Johnson）。我是加勒特·雷诺兹（Garrett Reynolds）。我们邀请你收听我们的新播客《We're Here to Help》。是的，我们是一个建议类播客，人们会打进电话诉说他们的问题，我们尝试提供帮助。我们尝试过，我们必须强调这一点，我们不是专业人士，甚至在这方面做得并不好。
So take our advice and listen to we're here to help, wherever you listen to podcasts. We got it! Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. On a November night, eight weeks before Vinzie Howe was attacked, she attended a party at a local pool center with her best friend, Polly. During the course of the evening, Vinzie became increasingly irritated at Polly's behavior. She felt Polly was being flirtatious and conceded with her new boyfriend, Wesley.
所以，听听我们的建议，收听《We're Here to Help》，无论你在哪里收听播客。我们搞定了！感谢你收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，你支持CaseFile继续提供高质量的内容。在文西·豪遇袭前八周的一个11月夜晚，她和闺蜜波莉参加了当地一个游泳中心举办的派对。在当晚的过程中，文西对波莉的行为越来越感到恼火。她觉得波莉在和她的新男友Wesley调情，并对此感到不满。
Vinci vented about this to some of the other girls in her friendship circle. When Polly caught wind of Vinci's complaints, an argument broke out between them. Everyone at the party saw the fight. It started with the pair shouting and swearing at each other before turning physical. Eventually, the two girls were pulled apart and they went their separate ways. Days later, Polly posted something on her Facebook page that Vinci took issue with. When Vinci's comment, though one of their mutual friends replied, Vinci, you have to be careful how you talk and you better learn from your mistakes.
文西向朋友圈里的其他女孩抱怨了这件事。当波莉听到文西的抱怨时，两人之间爆发了争吵。派对上的每个人都看到了这场争斗。它始于两人互相大喊大叫和咒骂，随后演变成肢体冲突。最终，两个女孩被拉开，她们分道扬镳。几天后，波莉在她的Facebook页面上发布了一些文西不认同的内容。当文西评论时，他们共同的朋友之一回复道：“文西，你说话得小心点，你最好从错误中吸取教训。”
Another friend wrote, Make Vinci stop because otherwise something serious will happen. While Polly didn't display any animosity towards Vinci online, offline she was seething. Although their friendship group was divided, many ultimately took Polly's side. She told her boyfriend Wesley that she hated Viny and wanted her out of her life. Despite having only just started dating Polly a few weeks prior, Wesley threw his support behind her. He encouraged his girlfriend's anger.
另一个朋友写道：“让文西停下来，否则会发生严重的事情。”虽然波莉在网上没有表现出对文西的敌意，但在现实生活中，她却怒火中烧。尽管她们的朋友圈分裂了，但许多人最终站在了波莉一边。她告诉男友Wesley，她讨厌文西，想让她从自己的生活中消失。尽管和波莉交往才几周，Wesley还是全力支持她。他助长了女友的愤怒。
A week after the party, Polly and Wesley composed a threatening text message which they sent to Vincey via Wesley's mobile phone. Vinci's reply to Wesley's text further enraged Polly. With the conflict escalating, Vinci's mother called Polly's mother to address the issue. They discussed Polly's behaviour, but their conversation had no impact on the conflict. Police anger soon reached boiling point. She informed her boyfriend that she wanted Vinci gone for good. Wesley suggested they find someone who could kill Vinci on their behalf.
派对一周后，波莉和Wesley写了一条威胁短信，通过Wesley的手机发给了文西。文西对Wesley短信的回复进一步激怒了波莉。随着冲突升级，文西的母亲打电话给波莉的母亲以解决问题。她们讨论了波莉的行为，但她们的谈话对冲突没有任何影响。波莉的愤怒很快达到了沸点。她告诉男友，她想让文西彻底消失。Wesley建议他们找人替他们杀掉文西。
The following weekend, Wesley and Polly went to a party in Arnhem. Polly spoke openly of how she wanted Vinci dead, but none of the party goers wanted to confront her about it. If they did, it could ruin the night. So they brushed their concerns off, refusing to take police threats seriously. To keep the peace, they made sure not to invite Vinci to the party. She showed up anyway. Polly was furious.
接下来的周末，Wesley和波莉去阿纳姆参加了一个派对。波莉公开谈论她想让文西死，但没有参加派对的人想就此与她对质。如果他们这样做，可能会毁了那个夜晚。所以他们不予理会，拒绝认真对待波莉的威胁。为了维持和平，他们确保没有邀请文西参加派对。但她还是出现了。波莉非常愤怒。
She confronted Vinci, called her derogatory names, pushed her and yelled, I'll kill you and I'll kill your family. Vinci was in tears. She seemed to genuinely shocked at the way her former best friend was now behaving towards her. Worse still, most of the pair's mutual friends continued to side with Polly, despite her increasingly volatile behavior. They were more upset that Vinci had ruined the party by attending. In the days that followed, Polly stepped up her campaign against Vinci.
她与文西对质，用侮辱性的名字称呼她，推搡她并大喊：“我会杀了你，我也会杀了你的家人。”文西泪流满面。她似乎对曾经最好的朋友现在对待她的方式感到非常震惊。更糟糕的是，尽管波莉的行为越来越不稳定，这对朋友的大多数共同朋友仍然站在波莉一边。他们更生气的是文西通过参加派对毁了气氛。在接下来的几天里，波莉加强了针对文西的行动。
Almost daily she bombarded her with death threats via text messages and social media. Vinci spent most of her time on the computer in her room, trying to seem unaffected and defiant in retorts she sent back to Polly. In reality, Vinci was growing increasingly fearful that Polly might follow through on her threats. But none of the pair's friends shared her concerns. One later spoke to Dutch Karen Affairs Program in Newseer, saying that she and everyone else in their friendship group
她几乎每天都通过短信和社交媒体用死亡威胁轰炸文西。文西大部分时间都待在房间里的电脑前，试图在回复波莉的信息时表现得不受影响且挑衅。实际上，文西越来越担心波莉可能会真的付诸行动。但这对朋友中没有人分享她的担忧。后来，其中一人在荷兰时事节目《EenVandaag》中说，她和朋友圈里的其他人
thought that police threats against Vinci had been empty. Polly was known for having an explosive personality and aggressive style of speaking. Even Vinci's parents had dismissed the issue, assuming it was just typical teenage bickering that was being blown out of proportion. Vinci's father, Chun Nam, told Newsyear that he believed the feud would fizzle out, and Vinci and Polly would become friends again. In actuality, Polly had started hatching her revenge less than a month after the fight began. Her boyfriend Wesley knew of a 14-year-old named Yinhua who was known to carry a knife.
都认为波莉对文西的威胁是空话。波莉以性格火爆和说话咄咄逼人而闻名。甚至文西的父母也忽视了这个问题，认为这只是典型的青少年争吵，被夸大了。文西的父亲春南告诉《EenVandaag》，他相信这场争执会平息，文西和波莉会重归于好。实际上，在争吵开始不到一个月后，波莉就开始策划她的复仇了。她的男友Wesley认识一个名叫Yinhua的14岁少年，此人以随身携带刀具而闻名。
Wesley was confident that Yinhua would do almost anything to gain his favour. He was right. When asked, Yinhua agreed to kill Vinci Hau. Just over two weeks later on Christmas Day, Polly and Wesley met up with the Yinhua at a snack bar in a village south of Rotterdam. There, the trio began planning Vinci's murder. Inwara had attempted to recruit others to participate in the slaughter, but hadn't found anyone willing to commit.
Wesley确信Yinhua为了获得他的青睐几乎什么都愿意做。他是对的。当被问及时，Yinhua同意杀害文西·豪。两周多后的圣诞节，波莉和Wesley在鹿特丹以南的一个村庄的快餐店与Yinhua见了面。在那里，三人开始策划文西的谋杀案。Yinhua曾试图招募其他人参与屠杀，但没有找到愿意动手的人。
He resolved that he would carry out the murder himself. Polly promised to pay Yinhua. While the final amount offered for the killing has never been confirmed, it was believed that it was somewhere between 50 to 100 euros, around 70 to 150 Australian dollars. Wesley also promised he would shut Yinhua drinks whenever they attended the same parties. Wesley and Yinhua kept in touch over the next few days, either in person, by phone or online, as they ironed out the details. Polly was either present for or aware of all these interactions.
他决定自己实施谋杀。波莉承诺付钱给Yinhua。虽然杀人的最终金额从未得到证实，但据信在50到100欧元之间，约合70到150澳元。Wesley还承诺，只要他们参加同一个派对，他就会请Yinhua喝酒。在接下来的几天里，Wesley和Yinhua通过当面、电话或在线方式保持联系，敲定细节。波莉要么在场，要么知道所有这些互动。
At first, it was decided that Yinhua would kill Vinci within the next few days. However, they decided to put their plans on hold until the new year. A week later, on Friday, January 6, 2012, Wesley handed Yinhua a piece of paper. On it, Polly had written the How Families Address, along with specific directions on how to get to the home via public transport. She'd even provided a description of the cartoon character decals on the glass next to Vinci's front door and the paintflex on the pavement in front. One week later, Polly called one of Vinci's classmates to find out what time Vinci would
起初，他们决定Yinhua在接下来的几天内杀掉文西。然而，他们决定将计划推迟到新年。一周后，2012年1月6日星期五，Wesley递给Yinhua一张纸。上面，波莉写下了豪家的地址，以及如何通过公共交通到达那里的具体路线。她甚至提供了文西前门旁边玻璃上的卡通贴纸描述，以及人行道上的油漆斑点。一周后，波莉打电话给文西的一位同学，询问文西那天几点放学回家。
be home from school that day. Wesley was present when his girlfriend made the call and passed the details on to Yin Hua. Yin Hua was already in Anum, waiting on Vinci's street. Our was passed, but Vinci never appeared. Frustrated, Yinhua gave up and left. Upon discovering that Vinci had not been killed as planned, Polly was furious. She insisted that Wesley contact Yinhua to organize another date for the murder. At about 9 the following evening, Wesley messaged Yunhua via Skype.
Wesley在女友打电话时在场，并将细节传达给了Yinhua。Yinhua当时已经在阿纳姆，在文西的街道上等待。一小时过去了，但文西一直没有出现。沮丧的Yinhua放弃并离开了。发现文西没有按计划被杀，波莉非常愤怒。她坚持要求Wesley联系Yinhua安排另一个谋杀日期。第二天晚上9点左右，Wesley通过Skype给Yinhua发了信息。
He confirmed that Vinci's parents would be acceptable collateral damage and set 3pm as the time of the attack. Police stood over her boyfriend as he typed, tomorrow you will do it. On the afternoon of Saturday, January 14, Yinhua traveled back to Vinci's house. He spoke to Wesley several times over the phone during the 90-minute journey. Wesley was with Polly and the two provided Yinhua Wesley several times over the phone during the 90 minute journey. Wesley was with Polly and the two provided Yenwa with encouragement to follow through
他确认文西的父母将是可接受的附带损害，并将下午3点定为袭击时间。波莉站在男友身后，看着他打字：“明天你就动手。”1月14日星期六下午，Yinhua再次前往文西家。在90分钟的旅程中，他多次通过电话与Wesley交谈。Wesley和波莉在一起，两人为Yinhua提供了鼓励，让他执行计划。
with the plan. It was nearing 3pm when Yenwa reached the three-story red brick terrace house belonging to the Hau family. The cartoon stickers on the window were alongside the blue front door and the white paint splattered on the pavement confirmed that Yinhua was at the right place. He approached the door and was led inside before attacking Vinci. When her father attempted to step in, Yinhua stabbed him too. After Polly's involvement in Vinci's murder was established, she was arrested. As with Yin Hua and Wesley, Polly was only referred to publicly by her
当Yinhua到达豪家那栋三层红砖排屋时，时间已接近下午3点。窗户上的卡通贴纸、蓝色的前门以及人行道上溅落的白色油漆证实Yinhua找对了地方。他走近门口，被领进屋内，随后袭击了文西。当她的父亲试图介入时，Yinhua也刺伤了他。在波莉参与文西谋杀案的事实被确定后，她被捕了。和Yinhua与Wesley一样，波莉在公开场合仅被称为
first name and to last initial, Polly W. Yin Hua was charged with Vinci's murder and the attempted manslaughter of her father, Chun Num Hau. Polly and Wesley were both charged with intentional incitement to murder. All three teens were held in juvenile detention while they awaited trial. Case file will be back shortly. Thank you for supporting us by listening to this episode's sponsors. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from Case File Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works for a long time now. It will be hosted by Raquel O'Brien, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves,
名字和姓氏首字母，即“Polly W”。Yinhua被控谋杀文西以及蓄意伤害其父亲春南·豪。波莉和Wesley都被控蓄意煽动谋杀。这三名青少年在等待审判期间都被关押在少年拘留所。Casefile稍后回来。感谢你通过收听本集的赞助商来支持我们。我很高兴宣布推出《Unfiltered》，这是Case File Presents旗下的最新播客。《Unfiltered》筹备已久。它将由拉奎尔·奥布莱恩主持，她非凡的播客《Silent Waves》
was the first show released on the Casefile Presents platform. After getting to know Raquel and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people from all walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind Although I don't host the show unfiltered has several tie-ins with case file The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given It's a long chat and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly Recall is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with.
是Casefile Presents平台上发布的第一档节目。在了解拉奎尔并看到她在采访各行各业的人时是多么有天赋后，我知道她必须拥有自己的对话式播客，于是《Unfiltered》诞生了。这是一个探索人类经验的播客。没有话题是禁区。这些原始而诚实的对话将为你打开一系列视角，并邀请你做出自己的判断。虽然我不是该节目的主持人，但《Unfiltered》与Casefile有几个关联。第一集包含了我有史以来第一次深度采访。这是一次长谈，你会了解到一些我从未公开谈论过的事情。拉奎尔是我唯一感到可以进行这种对话的人。
The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin Wat and his former sergeant John Deem joined Rikkel to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes. Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation. real stories about justice and transformation. The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for Unfiltered,
第二集的主角是Casefile第78案“Janabi家族案”中的两位关键证人。前美国士兵贾斯汀·怀特和他的前中士约翰·迪姆加入了拉奎尔，讲述他们在战争中的经历，以及揭露战争罪行是什么感觉。未来的剧集将邀请来自各行各业的多元化嘉宾。有些与Casefile的剧集或我们的Casefile Presents系列有关，而另一些则完全无关。但所有剧集都讲述了关于正义与转变的真实故事。包括我那期采访在内的前两集现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听，后续所有剧集将每周发布。请务必点击《Unfiltered》的关注按钮，
so you don't miss an episode. Hey everybody this is Jake Johnson and Garrett Reynolds. And we're inviting you to listen to our new podcast. We're here to help. Yeah, we're an advice podcast where people call in with their problems and we try to help. We try. We can't stress this enough. We are not professionals and we're not even very good at this.
这样你就不会错过任何一集。大家好，我是杰克·约翰逊。我是加勒特·雷诺兹。我们邀请你收听我们的新播客《We're Here to Help》。是的，我们是一个建议类播客，人们会打进电话诉说他们的问题，我们尝试提供帮助。我们尝试过。我们必须强调这一点。我们不是专业人士，甚至在这方面做得并不好。
So take our advice and listen to we're here to help. Wherever you listen to podcasts. We got it! Thank you for listening to this episode's ads. By supporting our sponsors, you support CaseFile to continue to deliver quality content. Yinhua K was the first of the three accused to be tried. His court proceedings began in August 2012, 7-months-safeter Vinci's murder. In the Netherlands, cases against mine as are usually heard behind closed doors. However, in Inwars case, the panel of three judges made the rare decision to conduct an open hearing. They determined that the public interest outweighed Inwars' individual rights.
所以，听听我们的建议，收听《We're Here to Help》。无论你在哪里收听播客。我们搞定了！感谢你收听本集的广告。通过支持我们的赞助商，你支持Casefile继续提供高质量的内容。Yinhua K是三名被告中第一个受审的。他的法庭程序始于2012年8月，即文西遇害7个月后。在荷兰，针对未成年人的案件通常闭门审理。然而，在Yinhua的案件中，由三名法官组成的合议庭做出了罕见的决定，进行公开听证。他们认为公共利益高于Yinhua的个人权利。
In relation to Vinci's murder, Inwai pleaded not guilty by reason of diminished responsibility. His defence council relied on two expert psychological reports. A specialist child and adolescent psychologist concluded that Inwai suffered from a serious behavioural disorder and psychopathic traits. The second report submitted by a panel of clinical psychologists stated that Yinhua placed extreme importance on fitting in with his peers. This man didn't even consider refusing Polly and Wesley's demands. In Yinhua's mind, killing Vinci was a guaranteed part to social acceptance.
关于文西的谋杀案，Yinhua以精神能力减弱为由辩称无罪。他的辩护律师依赖两份专家心理报告。一位专门研究儿童和青少年的心理学家得出结论，Yinhua患有严重的行为障碍和精神病态特征。由临床心理学家小组提交的第二份报告指出，Yinhua极其看重与同龄人的融合。这个男孩甚至没有考虑过拒绝波莉和Wesley的要求。在Yinhua看来，杀害文西是获得社会认可的必经之路。
Both reports concluded that In Wai should be regarded as having diminished responsibility on account of his defective mental, emotional and social development. The Defence Council also attempted to limit In Wai's responsibility by citing the extreme external pressure placed on him by Polly and Wesley. The defense claimed that Polly and Wesley threatened to kill Yinhua's parents if he did not do as they instructed. The court found no evidence to support these allegations, and concluded that Yinhua was a willing participant in the attacks. and concluded that Yin Wai was a willing participant in the attacks.
两份报告都得出结论，由于Yinhua在心理、情感和社会发展方面的缺陷，应被视为精神能力减弱。辩护律师还试图通过引用波莉和Wesley对他施加的极端外部压力来限制Yinhua的责任。辩方声称，如果Yinhua不按他们的指示行事，波莉和Wesley威胁要杀掉他的父母。法庭没有发现任何证据支持这些指控，并得出结论认为Yinhua是袭击的自愿参与者。
They were also satisfied that Yin Wai's actions were pre-meditated and not a spur of the moment decision made while Yin Wai was in a quote, blacked out state, as his lawyers had suggested. Yin Wai also pleaded not guilty to the attempted manslaughter of Chun Nam Ham-Hao. He maintained that he'd only defended himself from Chun-Nam, who attacked him. The court also rejected this claim, as Yin-Wa instigated the violent altercation with the Chun-Nam, and consciously chose to keep hold of his knife as he did so. The Skype correspondence between Yin-Wa and Wesley the day prior to the attack only further
他们还确信Yinhua的行为是蓄意的，而不是像他的律师所暗示的那样，是在“断片”状态下做出的冲动决定。Yinhua还对蓄意伤害春南·豪的指控辩称无罪。他坚持认为他只是在防御春南，因为春南袭击了他。法庭也驳回了这一说法，因为Yinhua挑起了与春南的暴力冲突，并且在冲突过程中有意识地选择紧握刀具。袭击前一天Yinhua和Wesley之间的Skype通信进一步
discredited Yin-Wa's claims. He had specifically asked if he should also kill Vinci's parents if they interfered and was told to do so. In his victim impact statement, Chun Nam-He spoke of how his life had turned into hell since the murder of his daughter. He also bore the physical scars of his life or death struggle with Vinci's killer. Chunnam implored the court to find Yinhua guilty and to sentence him as an adult rather than a juvenile.
否定了Yinhua的说法。他曾明确询问如果文西的父母干预，是否也应该杀掉他们，并得到了肯定的答复。在受害者影响陈述中，春南·豪讲述了自从女儿被谋杀后，他的生活是如何变成地狱的。他还带着与文西杀手生死搏斗留下的身体伤疤。春南恳求法庭判决Yinhua有罪，并将其作为成年人而非未成年人判刑。
Vinci's mother wasn't home at the time her daughter was set upon and has lived with that guilt ever since. Let suspects of this horrific act to get their deserved punishment, she told the court. The judges delivered their verdict two weeks later. In Waqe was found guilty for both the murder of Vinzi Hao and the attempted manslaughter of Chun Num Hao. As Yinhua was only 14 when he committed these crimes, Dutch laws for juvenile offenders applied.
文西的母亲在女儿遇袭时不在家，此后一直带着这种内疚生活。她告诉法庭：“让这起可怕行为的嫌疑人得到他们应得的惩罚。”法官两周后做出了判决。Yinhua K被判谋杀文西·豪和蓄意伤害春南·豪罪名成立。由于Yinhua犯罪时年仅14岁，荷兰针对未成年罪犯的法律适用。
These laws focused strongly on rehabilitation rather than punishment. As such, Inwai was sentenced to one year in juvenile detention and a further three years in a TBS. TBS is a criminal psychiatric facility where offenders received psychological and psychiatric counseling to help reintegrate them into society. This sentence was the maximum term permitted under Dutch law at the time. Chunnam-Hao called Yin-Wa's punishment offensive and urged politicians to consider revising the sentencing laws for exceptional cases such as this.
这些法律强烈关注康复而非惩罚。因此，Yinhua被判处一年少年拘留，并在TBS（刑事精神病院）接受三年治疗。TBS是一个刑事精神病设施，罪犯在那里接受心理和精神咨询，以帮助他们重新融入社会。这是当时荷兰法律允许的最高刑期。春南·豪称Yinhua的惩罚令人反感，并敦促政治家考虑修改此类特殊案件的量刑法律。
Polly W and Wesley C both pleaded not guilty to intentionally inciting Yinhua to murder Vinci. Through her lawyer, Polly claimed that her wish for Vinci to die was not meant to be taken literally. She said it was just a turn of phrase that was common in Chinese culture. However, no evidence was provided to prove this. Two psychological reports were submitted, with experts determining that Poly suffered from a delay in social-emotional development, identity problems, and a behavioral disorder.
Polly W和Wesley C均对蓄意煽动Yinhua谋杀文西的指控辩称无罪。通过律师，波莉声称她希望文西死的话并非字面意思。她说这只是中国文化中常见的口头禅。然而，没有提供任何证据证明这一点。提交了两份心理报告，专家确定波莉患有社会情感发展迟缓、身份认同问题和行为障碍。
Polly flatly denied threatening or incentivizing Inwata kill Vinci. The court rejected these arguments, finding ample evidence that Polly intended for Vinci to be killed. Wesley's defense argued there was no evidence that messages sent from Wesley's phone and social media were actually written by Wesley. They claimed that Polly was responsible for them instead. Wesley was depicted as a love struck teen who allowed Polly to have complete control over him. Wesley claimed that he hadn't wanted Vinci dead, he just wanted to scare her. Two psychological reports suggested that Wesley functioned at the intellectual and emotional
波莉断然否认威胁或诱导Yinhua杀害文西。法庭驳回了这些论点，发现有充分证据表明波莉意图杀害文西。Wesley的辩方辩称，没有证据表明从Wesley的手机和社交媒体发送的信息确实是由Wesley本人撰写的。他们声称波莉对此负责。Wesley被描绘成一个被爱情冲昏头脑的少年，允许波莉完全控制他。Wesley声称他并不想让文西死，他只是想吓唬她。两份心理报告表明，Wesley的智力和情感功能
level of an 11-year-old. They also indicated that Wesley had an overdependence and attachment to his mother, which transferred to Polly once they started dating. The court determined that there was close and conscious collaboration between Polly and Wesley in provoking Vinci's murder. Both teens were found guilty. The court stated that it was shocking and hard to comprehend that a seemingly trivial
处于11岁儿童的水平。他们还指出，Wesley对母亲有过度依赖和依恋，在他们开始约会后，这种依恋转移到了波莉身上。法庭认定，波莉和Wesley在煽动文西谋杀案中存在密切且有意识的合作。两名青少年均被判有罪。法庭表示，令人震惊且难以理解的是，两个年轻女孩之间看似微不足道的
quarrel between two young girls could turn a friendship into deep hatred and eventually lead to murder. The prosecution called for both Polly and Wesley to be sentenced as adults. This was permissible in exceptional cases where juvenile offenders were at least 16 years old. The court acknowledged the seriousness of the offences and the indescribable impact that Binsie's murder had on her family and the community. However, given Polly and Wesley's delayed emotional and intellectual development, the court determined that their sentence
争吵竟然能将友谊变成深仇大恨，并最终导致谋杀。检方要求将波莉和Wesley作为成年人判刑。这在未成年罪犯年满16岁的特殊案件中是允许的。法庭承认了罪行的严重性以及文西的谋杀对她的家人和社区造成的难以言表的冲击。然而，考虑到波莉和Wesley在情感和智力发展上的迟缓，法庭确定他们的判决
should focus primarily on rehabilitation, rather than retaliation. Polley and Wesley were sentenced to two years in juvenile detention, the maximum permissible under Dutch juvenile sentencing laws. Before they were eligible to be released back into society, the pair would be required to spend a time in a TBS. Polly would face three years in the TBS and Wesley too. The public prosecutor appealed these sentences, pushing again for polyand Wesley to be sentenced as adults. Both appeals were rejected. Wesley C was released in February 2017. A probation report explained that Wesley's emotional immaturity and attachment issues were treated through psychotherapy and behavioral
应主要侧重于康复，而非报复。波莉和Wesley被判处两年少年拘留，这是荷兰少年量刑法律允许的最高刑期。在他们有资格被释放回社会之前，两人将被要求在TBS度过一段时间。波莉将面临三年的TBS治疗，Wesley也是如此。检察官对这些判决提出上诉，再次推动将波莉和Wesley作为成年人判刑。两次上诉均被驳回。Wesley C于2017年2月获释。一份缓刑报告解释说，Wesley的情绪不成熟和依恋问题通过心理治疗和行为
interventions. The report also indicated that Wesley's socio-emotional disadvantages had been rectified, and that his self-insight had dramatically improved. His risk of recidivism was judged to be low. PolyW was released two weeks later. Polly's probation report indicated that she no longer suffered from a conduct or identity disorder, and no personality disorder had developed. Her risk of recidivism was judged to be low as long as she continued counseling. As a condition of their release, neither Polly nor Wesley were permitted to contact each other.
干预得到了治疗。报告还指出，Wesley的社会情感缺陷已得到纠正，他的自我洞察力有了显著提高。他再次犯罪的风险被评估为低。Polly W两周后获释。波莉的缓刑报告显示，她不再患有行为或身份障碍，也没有发展出人格障碍。只要她继续接受咨询，她再次犯罪的风险被评估为低。作为释放条件，波莉和Wesley均不得联系对方。
Both were required to continue psychological counselling and report regularly to authorities during their probation period. During this time, Yinhua K applied for release. The court determined that although he had undergone positive development, a few incidents had arisen during his rehabilitation where he made inappropriate choices. Concerns remained as to Yinhua's ability to appropriately deal with frustrations. Accordingly, he was ordered to remain in TBS. Inwa submitted a second application seven months later.
两人都被要求在缓刑期间继续接受心理咨询，并定期向当局报告。在此期间，Yinhua K申请释放。法庭认定，尽管他经历了积极的发展，但在康复过程中出现了一些事件，他做出了不恰当的选择。人们仍然担心Yinhua处理挫折的能力。因此，他被命令继续留在TBS。Yinhua七个月后提交了第二次申请。
His risk of recurrence was noted as low to moderate, primarily in relation to his impulsive behavior, lack of empathy, and insufficient cooperation with certain TBS interventions. However, the court found that Yinhua exhibited a less risky behavior, had demonstrated an ability to withstand disappointments and manage responsibilities, and showed a willingness to seek help. The court determined that he no longer posed a serious risk of violent crime. Rejecting the public prosecutor's request to further extend Yinhua's custody arrangements, the court approved Yinhua's release in September 2017, subject to stringent conditions. Yinhua was required to regularly report to probation services, refrain from drug and alcohol use,
他再次犯罪的风险被记录为低至中等，主要与他的冲动行为、缺乏同理心以及在某些TBS干预措施中配合不足有关。然而，法庭发现Yinhua表现出较少的危险行为，证明了自己有能力承受失望和管理责任，并表现出寻求帮助的意愿。法庭认定他不再构成严重的暴力犯罪风险。法庭驳回了检察官进一步延长Yinhua监禁安排的请求，批准Yinhua于2017年9月获释，但须遵守严格的条件。Yinhua被要求定期向缓刑服务部门报告，禁止使用毒品和酒精，
follow a strict daily routine, and grant authorities access to his social media accounts and finances. In April of the following year, an advertisement appeared online for the sale of several expensive pieces of computer equipment. The seller, whom Casefile will refer to as Mark, was contacted by an interested buyer. Two men arrived at Mark's house that evening. Mark told the telegraph newspaper that he opened the door to two neat looking and friendly men of East Asian appearance, presumably a father and son. The two men collected the computer equipment.
遵循严格的日常作息，并允许当局访问他的社交媒体账户和财务状况。次年4月，网上出现了一则出售几件昂贵电脑设备的广告。Casefile将称之为“马克”（Mark）的卖家被一位感兴趣的买家联系。那天晚上，两名男子来到马克的家。马克告诉《每日电讯报》，他打开门，看到两名看起来整洁且友好的东亚裔男子，推测是父子。两人取走了电脑设备。
Instead of handing over the agreed 4,000 euros as payment, the older of the man pulled out a gun and pointed it directly at Mark's head. The young man ordered Mark onto his knees and instructed him to count to 60 before moving. He threatened to shoot Mark, his girlfriend, and their baby, if Mark attempted anything as the men were leaving. After Mark was certain they had driven away, he called the police. It took the police a few weeks before they had the two armed robbers in custody. The younger one was Yanhua K. News of Yanhua's violent re-offending brought pain to Chunnam-Hao, who was still coming to
年长的那名男子没有交出约定的4000欧元作为报酬，而是掏出一把枪直接指着马克（Mark）的头。这名年轻人命令马克跪下，并指示他数到60才能动。他威胁马克，如果他在他们离开时有任何动作，就杀了马克、他的女友和他们的孩子。在确认他们开车离开后，马克报了警。警方花了几个星期才将这两名持枪抢劫犯逮捕归案。较年轻的那位是严华·K（Yanhua K）。严华再次暴力犯罪的消息给春南·豪（Chunnam-Hao）带来了痛苦，他当时还在努力接受
terms with the loss of his daughter. He told the telegraph, I am not at all surprised that Yin Hua has made a mistake again. He is severely disturbed that was evident from the murder. Chun Nam further commented, I like the idea that Yinhua is now in jail. I hope for myself and for society that Yinhua stays inside forever. During the investigation into Vinci House murder, investigators examined online and phone records of Yinhua, Polly, Wesley and their friends.
失去女儿的事实。他告诉《每日电讯报》：“对于严华再次犯错，我一点也不感到惊讶。他精神严重失常，这一点从谋杀案中就很明显。”春南进一步评论道：“我很高兴严华现在被关进监狱。为了我自己，也为了社会，我希望严华永远待在里面。”在对文奇（Vinci）谋杀案的调查过程中，调查人员检查了严华、波莉（Polly）、韦斯利（Wesley）及其朋友的在线记录和通话记录。
They soon realized that the murder plot wasn't a well-kept secret between the three involved. In fact, many other youths were well aware of it. Two hours before Vinci was attacked, a friend of Yinhua's posted on Facebook. A girl is going to die at 3pm today. 19 minutes later, at 123, the post received its first response. The user wrote, Oh my god. Yet, no one called the police. The post remained up long after Vininci and her father had been struck.
他们很快意识到，谋杀计划并非这三人之间严守的秘密。事实上，许多其他年轻人都知道这件事。在文奇遇袭前两小时，严华的一位朋友在Facebook上发帖称：“一个女孩今天下午3点要死了。”19分钟后，即1点23分，该帖子收到了第一条回复。用户写道：“天哪。”然而，没有人报警。在文奇和她父亲遇袭很久之后，这条帖子依然存在。
One user responded to the post about an hour and a half after the attack, writing, Whoa, I just saw it on the newsman. Damn. Just over an hour after that, another user responded to the post with a warning that read, Watch out! The police also have Facebook. Many more of Polly and Vinci's friends were aware of the plot since its inception.
袭击发生约一个半小时后，一名用户回复了该帖子，写道：“哇，我刚在新闻上看到了。该死。”一个多小时后，另一名用户回复该帖子并发出警告：“小心！警察也在看Facebook。”波莉和文奇的许多朋友从一开始就知道这个计划。
One of Vinci's friends told a news year, If everyone who knew about it, who should have reported something but didn't, then I think that 60 people should be arrested for being complicit. You know, because everyone knew about it. Everyone knew about it. Ultimately, no one who remained silent while knowing that Vinci was in danger was charged with any crimes. I am excited to announce the launch of Unfiltered, the latest podcast from CaseFile Presents. Unfiltered has been in the works
文奇的一位朋友告诉新闻媒体：“如果所有知道这件事、本该举报却没举报的人都要负责，那么我认为应该有60个人因共谋罪被捕。你知道，因为每个人都知道。每个人都知道。”最终，那些在明知文奇处于危险中却保持沉默的人，没有一人受到任何刑事指控。我很高兴地宣布《Unfiltered》上线，这是CaseFile Presents推出的最新播客。《Unfiltered》已经筹备
for a long time now. It will be hosted by Rikello Bryan, whose extraordinary podcast, Silent Waves, was the first show released on the Casefile Presents platform. After getting to know Rikell and seeing how talented she is at interviewing people from all walks of life, I knew that she had to have her own conversation style podcast, and thus unfiltered was born. A podcast that provides an exploration into human experiences. No topic is off limits. These raw and honest conversations will open you up to a range of perspectives and invite you to make up your own mind.
了很长一段时间。它将由里凯洛·布莱恩（Rikello Bryan）主持，她的非凡播客《Silent Waves》是CaseFile Presents平台上发布的第一档节目。在了解了里凯尔并看到她采访各行各业人士的天赋后，我知道她必须拥有自己的对话式播客，于是《Unfiltered》诞生了。这是一个探索人类体验的播客。没有禁忌话题。这些真实而坦诚的对话将为你打开一系列视角，并邀请你做出自己的判断。
Although I don't host the show, unfiltered has several tie-ins with CaseFile. The first episode features the first in-depth interview I've ever given. It's a long chat and you'll get to know some things about me that I've never spoken about publicly. Rekal is the only person I felt comfortable having this conversation with. The second episode stars two key witnesses from Case 78 of Case File, the Janabi family. Former US soldier Justin Wat and his former sergeant John Deem joined Rikkel to speak about their experiences in war and what it was like to blow the whistle on war crimes.
虽然我不是节目的主持人，但《Unfiltered》与CaseFile有几个关联。第一集包含了我有史以来第一次深度访谈。这是一次长谈，你会了解到一些我从未公开谈论过的事情。里凯尔是我唯一觉得可以进行这种对话的人。第二集的主角是CaseFile第78案中的两位关键证人，即贾纳比（Janabi）一家。前美国士兵贾斯汀·沃特（Justin Wat）和他的前中士约翰·迪姆（John Deem）与里凯尔一起谈论了他们在战争中的经历，以及揭露战争罪行是什么样的体验。
Future episodes feature a diverse range of guests from all walks of life. Some are connected to case file episodes or one of our case file presents series, while others are completely unrelated. But all feature real stories about justice and transformation. real stories about justice and transformation. The first two episodes, including my interview, are available now wherever you get your podcasts, with all subsequent episodes to be released weekly. Be sure to hit the follow button for unfiltered, so you don't miss an episode. On 15 December 2014, a lone wolf terrorist inspired by Islamic State walked into the link cafe in Sydney's Martin Place, armed with a pump-action shotgun, and the threat of a backpack bomb. Over 16 hours, he held 18 hostages captive in a siege that was live-streamed around the world.
未来的剧集将邀请各行各业的多元化嘉宾。有些人与CaseFile剧集或我们的CaseFile Presents系列有关，而另一些则完全无关。但所有节目都讲述了关于正义与转变的真实故事。关于正义与转变的真实故事。前两集，包括我的访谈，现在可以在你获取播客的任何地方收听，后续所有剧集将每周发布。请务必点击《Unfiltered》的关注按钮，这样你就不会错过任何一集。2014年12月15日，一名受伊斯兰国启发的独狼恐怖分子携带一把泵动式霰弹枪和背包炸弹的威胁，走进了悉尼马丁广场的林特咖啡馆（Lindt Cafe）。在16个小时的时间里，他扣押了18名人质，进行了一场向全球直播的围攻。
18 hostages captive in a siege that was live streamed around the world. Tiger Tiger Tiger tells the untold story of the courageous actions of the New South Wales Tactical Operations Unit. This book will challenge what you thought you knew about the Lint siege, with details that show how willing the tactical operations unit operators were to sacrifice their lives. But Tiger Tiger Tiger is more than an edge of your seat inside his perspective on Australia's first terrorist hostage rescue mission. Written by the officer who shot and killed the terrorist, this extraordinary frontline account provides an insight into the psychological damage done in the line of duty. It offers a message of resilience and hope for everyone.
18名人质在围攻中被扣押，这场围攻向全球进行了直播。《Tiger Tiger Tiger》讲述了新南威尔士州战术行动小组英勇行动的未公开故事。这本书将挑战你对林特咖啡馆围攻事件的既有认知，其中的细节展示了战术行动小组的成员是多么愿意牺牲自己的生命。《Tiger Tiger Tiger》不仅仅是一个让你紧张到坐立不安的视角，带你深入了解澳大利亚首次恐怖分子人质救援任务。由击毙恐怖分子的警官撰写，这份非凡的前线记录提供了对履行职责所造成的心理创伤的洞察。它为每个人提供了关于韧性和希望的信息。
Tiger, tiger, tiger had me gripped from start to end. I finished it in two days because I simply couldn't put it down. Visit tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com to grab your copy. That's tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com That's Tyga Tyga Book. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
《Tiger Tiger Tiger》让我从头到尾都沉浸其中。我两天就读完了，因为我根本放不下。访问tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com获取你的副本。那是tiger, tiger, tiger, book.com，也就是Tyga Tyga Book。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。